bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant en direct de l'hémicycle
la séance de questions cribles alors les
questions cribles vous le savez ce sont
ces questions très précises que posent
les sénateurs un ministre le thème
aujourd'hui c'est l'accès au financement
bancaire des petites moyennes et très
petites entreprises et le ministre c'est
arnaud montebourg ministres de
l'économie et du redressement productif
voilà on se retrouve au site après sur
hit monsieur yannick vaugrenard pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre si le financement bancaire est
essentielle au fonctionnement notre
économie il est crucial pour les petites
et moyennes entreprises ainsi que pour
les très petites entreprises
en effet elle recourt très souvent
crédits bancaires pour financer leurs
investissements sur le long et moyen
terme pour des crédits à court terme
également ou encore plus fréquemment
peut-être pour répondre à leurs besoins
de trésorerie
le financement bancaire et donc la
pierre angulaire du financement de nos
pme et tpe qui avec plus de la moitié
des effectifs salariés sont fortement
pourvoyeuse d'emplois et d'activités sur
nos territoires les entreprises
artisanales représente 30% du nombre
d'entreprises 14 % de l'emploi salarié
et créer 10 % de notre valeur ajoutée
or ces entrepreneurs se plaignent de
manière récurrente des difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent en matière
d'accessibilité aux crédits bancaires
paradoxalement les enquêtes
trimestrielles de la banque de france
semble démentir elle montre que la
demande de crédits des pme et tpe est
majoritairement satisfaites
le taux d'obtention s'est globalement
maintenue et demeurent élevés pour les
pme ainsi que les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire puisque plus de huit
entreprises sur dix obtiendrait
totalement en grande partie ce qu'elles
ont demandé pour autant je suis
convaincu que la perception des chefs
d'entreprise est fondée je pense
notamment problèmes de trésorerie qui
précarisent nos petites entreprises
comme l'a souligné madame prost
médiatrice du crédit lors de son
audition par une autre commission des
affaires économiques
en février dernier je cite les banques
commerciales doivent financer les
petites entreprises
il faut que le système bancaire finance
l'économie réelle
nous devons veiller à ce que les
banquiers ne s'égare pas dans des
activités spéculatives
nous savons que le gouvernement a mis en
place de nombreux soutiens aux
entreprises avec la banque publique
d'investissement notamment
mais les banques privées doivent aussi
se mobiliser pour consolider la
croissance qui peut repartir
c'est pourquoi nous aimerions connaître
monsieur le ministre les actions que le
gouvernement compte mener dans cette
direction je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous à la
parole de monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yannick vaugrenard vous faites
état d écart entre le ressenti de
terrain des dirigeants d'entreprises et
les statistiques sur les encours de
crédits et les octrois par le secteur et
le système bancaire lorsqu'on ne se
contente pas d'une analyse générale mais
qu'on entre dans le détail on réconcilie
très vite ce ressenti et la réalité des
statistiques car j'ai là le rapport de
madame jeanne marie pro la médiatrice du
crédit qu'elle a destiné à son ministre
de tutelle
elle a dit devant vous une vérité assez
clair c'est que aujourd'hui vous avez
des taux de réussite de crédit qui sont
demandées par des dirigeants de pme ou
de tpe qui sont s'agissant de la
trésorerie qui sont à peu près
l'équivalent de ce qui existe en italie
et même en espagne c'est à dire là où il
n'a presque plus de secteur bancaire en
état de fonctionner normalement
68 % des pme ont obtenu en partie ou
totalité des crédits de trésorerie
demandé après 74 % au trimestre
précédent donc il ya aujourd'hui des
phénomènes de tension sur la
distribution du crédit à travers le
secteur bancaire qu'est ce que fait le
gouvernement face à cette situation là
où le canot n'arrive plus à desservir
par l'irrigation naturel l'économie
réelle danizan creusons d'autres nous
l'avons fait d'abord avec la banque
publique d'investissement est une banque
qui a pour but je l' ai toujours dit de
concurrencer le secteur privé banques
erc
ne fait pas de façon satisfaisante son
travail qui s'est éloigné de l'économie
réelle est d'ailleurs il ya un phénomène
qui ne trompent guère
c'est là les qualifications dans les
agences de terrain et la capacité
finalement des personnels émérite du
secteur bancaire à ne plus être capable
de faire des diagnostics cliniques comme
si les médecins finalement vous n'êtes
plus capables de diagnostiquer et
renvoyé en permanence à des laboratoires
éloigné des analyses médicales et c'est
ce qui se passe dans les banques
vous n'avez plus personne qui prend le
diagnostic qu'il assume qui accompagne
et qui fait le risque et qui le prend
pour le compte de la banque et donc vous
avez là finalement un éloignement qui
est dénoncé par la médiatrice du crédit
dans les activités de marché purement
spéculatives dans tous les domaines et
l'économie réelle est laissée à
l'abandon la bpi a pour objectif de
supplée à cette carence ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs le seul canaux que nous
souhaitons favoriser mais c'est un point
important les chiffres que nous sommes
en mesure de vous donner sont
intéressants rapidement monsieur le
ministre vous avez épuisé le temps de
parole de réponse mais vous y reviendrez
certainement dans le court je vous en
plus de temps sur des choses qui
arrivent
j'aurais dû être beaucoup plus concis
nous avons des progressions d'encours de
6% en 2013 objectif fixé par le
directeur général de la banque publique
d'investissement c'est + 30% en 2014
voilà donc nous avons un outil qui
permet de progresser il y en a d'autres
gens dire très bien merci en demandant
d'autres collègues d'être peut-être un
peu plus brève que la minute prévue
très bien merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur mise pour votre pour
votre réponse
vous m'avez répondu bien sûr
partiellement j'ai bien compris par
rapport à la banque publique
d'investissement malheureusement j'ai le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas suffisamment de réponses vous venez
en avoir c'est la question que je pose
en direction des banques privées et vous
l'avez souligné fort justement monsieur
le ministre les centres de décisions
sont de plus en plus éloignées entre
le responsable des petites et moyennes
entreprises ou des très petites
entreprises sans décision existe la
plupart du temps à paris où sont
extrêmement centralisé et ce n'est plus
le directeur d'agencé qui délivre le
crédit notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
crédits trésorerie donc cette relation
de confiance qui existaient voici
quelques années n'existe plus
aujourd'hui et c'est fort dommageable
donc je souhaite que les interventions
plus haut niveau auprès des grands
organismes bancaires pour que cette
manière d'agir si possible le seysses
merci la parole d'un ami ray ils
cherchent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la séparation des activités
bancaires pour financer l'activité
économique et la création de la banque
publique d'investissement figurait parmi
les mesures fort de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 alors que les
difficultés d'accès au crédit des pme et
tpe demeure une réalité il est difficile
de comprendre que ce débat financier
était absent de la discussion sur le
projet de loi relatif au commerce et à
l'artisanat adopté ce matin
en effet les trésoreries des entreprises
reste très tendue ainsi en auvergne plus
d'une entreprise sur deux voies sa
trésorerie se réduire cela depuis trop
longtemps
beaucoup d'entreprises ne peuvent plus
faire face sans le soutien du secteur
bancaire
la séparation des activités bancaires
n'a pas été à la hauteur des enjeux
les banques ne se sont pas éloignés des
logiques de rentabilité logique qui
pousse à accroître les taux d'intérêt
imposés aux petites entreprises
de plus l'existence de la bpi du fait
des faibles montants engagés par cet
établissement 7 milliards d'euros soit
environ 1 % de la demande annuelle de
crédit n'a pas réellement répondu aux
attentes suscitées par sa création ainsi
la croissance demeure par des
coûts et surcoûts bancaire qui affecte
sérieusement les pme et tpe et constitue
aujourd'hui la moitié des cotisations
sociales dites patronales
il est donc urgent que la bpi puis jouer
pleinement son rôle et dispose de
ressources suffisantes pour aider ces
entreprises petites certes mais première
employeur de france aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre pourquoi ne pas lui confier
une partie des éventuels excédents du
fonds des pagnes alimentée par la
collecte du livret a
comme du livret de développement durable
ne doit-on pas lui permettre d'obtenir
des ressources de crédit auprès de la
banque centrale européenne comme le
ferait n'importe quel autre
établissement de crédit je vous remercie
merci monsieur arnaud montebourg la
sénatrice la bpi est en grande
croissance les banques privées
connaissent d'autres formes de
croissance amorcée l'envolée des bonus
j'ai même noter que les rémunérations
des dirigeants de banques ont progressé
dans les proportions absolument à
descente je vois que le pdg du crédit
agricole à lui une augmentation de 38 %
natixis + 14 bpce +29 donc il va falloir
qu'on discute de tout cela avec la place
bancaire qu'on ne peut pas avoir un
système bancaire défaillant et des
rémunérations et des profits qui
s'envole dans les proportions qui sont à
nos yeux disproportionnée donc il va y
aura un petit rendez vous de discussion
et le premier ministre me l'a demandé
donc je vais évidemment le faire sur la
bpi là ce sont des chiffres beaucoup
plus intéressant parce que nous avons
des progressions de 11 % en 2013
notamment sur les solutions de
trésorerie qui est le point de tension
vous signalé à juste titre l'activité de
garantie des prêts bancaires là aussi
les progressions sont très importantes
ses + 20 % vous avez s'agissant des
activités d'investissement plus 50%
prévus pour 2014
ce sont des milliers d'entreprises qui
sont concernés par l'activité de la bpi
3000 dans les prés de développement 3600
dans les prés pour l'innovation sur les
activités d'investissement passe de 121
millions investis en fonds propres
l'année passée on va passer à 170
millions donc ce travail continue
je pourrais parler également du
préfinancement du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi qui a permis de
renforcer la trésorerie des entreprises
par anticipation sur le dispositif
ce sont là des progrès appréciables
je voudrais aussi signalé un point qui
est aussi un des éléments de réponse que
pourrait réserver à monsieur vaugrenard
le gouvernement dans les entreprises en
difficulté
a mis en place un fonds de résistance
économique qui est la réhabiliter en
marche de l'ancien faisait ce fonds de
développement économique et social pour
un montant de 380 millions c'est grâce à
cette banque d'état qui travaille aux
conditions du marché
toujours de façon minoritaire
sollicitant d'ailleurs la place qui est
au rendez vous qu'on a sauvés quel
moines qu'on a permis aussi de sauver
malgré d'énormes sacrifices
malheureusement maurice ducros que nous
avons sauvé fagorbrandt et que nous
allons sauver certainement ascométal ce
sont en tout et pour tout déjà à l'actif
du fonds de résistance économique
cinquante mille emplois directs ou
indirects qui ont été préservés
les banques ne sont pas au rendez vous
la banque s'est nous monsieur le
sénateur madame la sénatrice
donc il va falloir que nous fassions
progresser ce secteur dans le sens d'un
meilleur patriotisme économique merci
madame mireille schurch merci monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse et j'en
prends acte bien sûr en indiquant qu'à
mon avis ce serait fourvoyé la bpi que
de la cantonner seulement à l'action
publique que général du gouvernement
qu'il s'agisse du ceis yeux ou du pack
de responsabilité outre le fait que le
président de la banque que sa première
vice-présidente viennent d'être appelés
à d'autres fonctions
ce qui témoigne à notre avis d'une
certaine légèreté pour l'action menée
par la bpi au moment où certains nous
assène tous les jours un discours
consternant sur la baisse des taux de
marge
il me semble plus que nécessaire que
nous facilitions l'existence de crédit
bancaire moins cher et moins prédateurs
pour les pme tpe j'ai entendu votre
votre votre vos propos dans ma région
l'auvergne les engagements pris par la
bpi sont deux montants faibles trop
faible alors que 66% des entreprises ont
saisi le médiateur du crédit
j'ai bien noté monsieur le ministre que
vous avez expliqué les progrès app et si
appréciable de la bpi j'ai envie de vous
dire peut mieux faire
ce simple fait mérite pour le moins que
nous visions à réduire le poids de la
finance dans l'économie et que soient
servis l'économie réelle et l'emploi non
délocalisable de nos territoires
merci la parole à jean vincent placé
pour le groupe écologiste
merci chers collègues monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues les données relatives au
financement bancaire des pme sont
contradictoires d'un côté un certain
nombre d'études rapporte que le manque
croissant de financement et la première
difficulté à laquelle font face les
dirigeants de pme je pense par exemple à
l'étude de la bce en mars 2013 encore au
baromètre trimestriel la cgpme et du
cabinet kpmg contraire la banque de
france publie régulièrement des chiffres
décrivant depuis un an une légère
progression de l'encours des crédits aux
pme et un fort taux de satisfaction de
la demande
quoi qu'il en soit il convient de
mobiliser tous les outils à notre
disposition enfin l'investissement privé
comme public qui si les stratégies
tirera toute notre économie vers le haut
à cet égard on ne peut que regretter
monsieur le ministre que cette belle
initiative que constitue la bpi servent
aujourd'hui essentiellement à sauver les
apparences du déficit public en assurant
le préfinancement du cic eux en lieu et
place de l'état
ce n'est pas son rôle et il n'y a là
aucun critère c'est linverse d'un
investissement stratégique
par ailleurs nous avons en matière
d'investissements une ressource toujours
inexploité mais je veux parler des
assurances vie en avait parlé à
l'automne dernier dans le cadre des
débats budgétaires des assurances vie
qui bénéficient d'un régime fiscal très
avantageux sans pour autant être affecté
un financement d'intérêt général
monsieur le ministre pourquoi ne
fêterons fait traitons pas vers la bpi
quelques pourcents de l'énorme en cours
d assurance vie qui atteignait l'année
dernière près de 1400 milliards d'euros
cela lui donnerait enfin les moyens de
piloter l'investissement dans les
filières d'avenir écologique et sociale
notre pays on a grandement besoin
alors qu'il s'apprête enfin à initier sa
transition écologique tant attendu
notamment des écologistes mais aussi et
surtout de l'ensemble de la population
française
enfin et je conclus j'ai parlé du rôle
de la bpm il y aurait aussi beaucoup à
dire des banques privées elles ont
récupéré cet été 30 milliards
supplémentaires issus de la collecte du
livret a
et du ldd et ne semble pas que cette
somme est réellement bénéficié au
financement l'économie et notamment des
pme comme elle s'y était engagée
comptez vous monsieur le ministre lancé
une évaluation la récente attribution
aux banques de cette manne publique
supplémentaire merci monsieur le
ministre pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
président nous avons beaucoup de travail
en la matière est d'une certaine manière
la convergence des propos qui sont
exprimées ici montrant les détails des
défaillances croissante du secteur privé
bancaire la taille encore trop petit de
la bpi c'est votre peut mieux faire
madame la sénatrice et je le prend pied
de la lettre
non pas comme une critique mais comme un
encouragement et la question de
l'assurance vie montre finalement nous
n'avons pas le système de financement
optimal que s'est il passé dans tous ces
pays où finalement les banques ont été
depuis la faillite de lehman brothers
ont disparu en quelque sorte du
financement de l'économie réelle les
entreprises sont passées par le marché
elles ont créé des compartiments de
financement avec des systèmes plus ou
moins réglementée plus ou moins
accueillants pour le risque et nous
avons un ratio qui traditionnellement
étaient 75 % de financement bancaire 25%
de financement de marché répartition
d'être capital et bien le ratio est en
train d'évoluer à une vitesse assez
spectaculaire puisque on est en train de
passer à 35 65%
nous souhaitons stimuler c'est ce que
j'appelais creuser les cadeaux parallèle
puisque le principal est embourbé et ne
fait plus sûr qui circulaient les flux
d'argent
nous souhaitons stimuler ses capacités
et parmi ceux-là l'assurance vie est une
solution d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'initiatives ont été prises après une
première réforme du code des assurances
qui a permis le lancement d'un fonds de
prêts destinés à permettre aux assureurs
de contribuer au financement en dette en
pme et eti nous espérons construire des
solutions pour un montant total de 50
milliards d'euros destinés ces terres à
peu près 4 % de l'encours ce qui ne
serait pas rien c'est peu par rapport
aux 1400 milliards que vous signalez
mais l'assurance vie n'a pas pour
destination ce
éternel de devoir assurer le financement
de la dette souveraine de tous les pays
de la zone euro elle doit aussi en
raison notamment de l'effort fiscal qui
est fait vis-à-vis de de ce produit
d'épargné en prisé des français se
consacrer à l'économie réelle donc c'est
un sujet dont nous reparlerons
et je vous remercie d'avoir posé cette
question merci monsieur place et très
bien merci c'est très généreux
merci la parole est à jean claude
requier pour le groupe rdse
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mitchell collègues
les bonnes nouvelles annoncées récemment
par la banque de france concernant
l'amélioration de l'accès au crédit
bancaire pour les pme au premier
trimestre 2014 ne doit pas masquer un
certain nombre de difficultés qui
demeurent en particulier pour les très
petites entreprises dans les tpe
tout d'abord même si le tour pme qui
parvient à obtenir au moins 75 % de la
somme demandée pour les crédits de
trésorerie a progressé pour atteindre 10
% ce taux reste significativement plus
faible que celui d'obtention des crédits
d'investissement qui lui est de 90%
or les difficultés de trésorerie menace
la survie d'un grand nombre de pme et
surtout de paix de tpe
force est de constater malgré les
avancées permises notamment par les
emplois de la banque publique
d'investissement que toutes les
entreprises ne sont pas égales face à
l'accès au crédit bancaire
même parmi les pme et tpe la taille de
l'entreprise est directement corrélé au
satisfaction quant à l'obtention d'un
crédit plus l'entreprise est petite et
plus l'accès au financement et difficile
ce problème demeure est très inquiète en
noir les des pme qui faut-il rappeler
représentent 89% et plus d'entreprises
françaises et 52 % de l'emploi salarié
mettre la clé sous la porte
parce qu'ils leur manquent quelques
milliers d'euros de trésorerie en outre
les données communiquées par la banque
de phrases ne prenait pas en
considération que les demandes de
crédits effectivement exprimé par les
entreprises or malheureusement nombre
d'entre elles et surtout le plus petit
renonce tout simplement à demander un
crédit de peur de se heurter à un refus
dans ces conduits dans ce contexte
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour aider efficacement les
plus petites entreprises et ne pas
laisser disparaître à raison de
difficultés par arrière de trésorerie
merci monsieur ni ce que vous êtes
apparu merci monsieur réquier je
voudrais d'abord en préambule à la
réponse que vous suscitez vous dire que
95% des décisions prises par la bpi sont
pris sur le terrain en région dans un
rapport direct avec les entreprises les
tpe et donc c'est une banque de terrains
sur le terrain aux côtés du terrain et
les élus locaux qui sont dans les dents
les comités d'orientation notamment les
régions sont très attentifs à ce que les
décisions soient prises au plus près des
territoires c'est un point très
important quand je vous aurais montré
que l'année 2013 a été marquée par un
très fort développement des solutions de
trésorerie notamment pour les toutes
petites entreprises avec une croissance
de 11% des mobilisations de créances
professionnel 3 milliards 3
d'autorisation de d'euros le lancement
en mars 2013 du préfinancement ici chez
eux ça concerne douze mille entreprises
qui sont pour la plupart des peu toutes
petites entreprises moins de 10 salariés
et la dynamisation de la garantie sur
les crédits bancaires de trésorerie
d'ailleurs il ya un effet pervers qui
est en train de s'installer
c'est que maintenant les banques privées
d'ici là bpi n'est pas autour de la
table
et bien moi je ne bouge plus ce qui est
un problème c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons besoin de faire
grossir la bpi su selon la suggestion de
madame la sénatrice heures et de faire
en sorte que en effet la bpi puisse
répondre présent parce qu'en fait elle
est agent de garantie du secteur privé
qui préfère faire ses profits augmenter
la rémunération de ses dirigeants dans
les proportions délirantes ailleurs et
ça c'était un problème pour la nation
c'est donc une raison la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes évidemment attentif
à la mobilisation de l'épargné
tout à l'heure a été évoquée par un
orateur le pe a et notamment les livrets
d'épargné qui ont été donnés à l'un des
deux grands actionnaires de la bpi la
caisse des dépôts et consignations et
donc il y a là une mobilisation de
l'épargné
je dois vous dire que nous travaillons
avec mes équipes dans le cadre de
l'évolution de la politique monétaire de
la banque centrale européenne vers les
politiques dites non conventionnelles du
quantitative easing tel que le font les
américains les anglais les japonais à ce
que nous puissions muscler notre secteur
bancaire est améliorée en quelque sorte
l'irrigation de l'économie réelle donc
nous y travaillons et nous
communiquerons des propositions que nous
ferons aux autorités monétaires
européennes dans les semaines à venir
avec mon collègue et ami michel sapin
merci monsieur requier sur cologne a
simplement répliqué quatre choses du lot
par le côté optimiste c'est que le
crédit pour les crédits bancaires pour
les pme s'est assouplie mais troisième
quiétude d'abord c'est que ces crédits
sont quand même un sa nation
dernièrement le tpe qui déclare avoir
effectué une demande de financement
auprès des banques est en diminution
et troisièmement les prévisions
d'investissement sont en berne pour les
pme sur les pointes pour les entreprises
et les pme en partie les tpe en
particulier eh bien elles ont besoin de
visibilité de stabilité et de confiance
mais comme chacun sait la confiance ne
se décrète pas merci la parole à francis
delattre pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président messieurs
mais l'issue est d'imposer cette
question ameliste volontariste pour lui
dire que la loi de finances 2013
et malheureusement c'était reconduire
dans la loi de finances 2014
il ya un très mauvais dispositif qui a
été entre qui a été introduit qui est la
non déductibilité partiel fiscale des
intérêts des prêts que font les
entreprises fort investissement
au moment où nous savons que les marges
sont réduites que problème des
investissements et cruel de vouloir
quelque part même si ç'a passé
relativement inaperçu
c'est quelque chose où aujourd'hui les
entreprises découvrent avec leur
comptable c'est quand même un
prélèvement encore 2,4 milliards
et dans un pays comme vous l'avez très
bien dit où le l'accès au financement
qui devrait être normal à la fois par là
bas la bourse qui n'existe pratiquement
plus à paris par l'earl épargne qui est
malheureusement est plutôt rentière dans
ce pays
il est évident qu'on a un vrai problème
est que les banques n'ont pas d'autre
solution que de faire avec les prêts
bancaires
or pour les pme et pmi c'est même 90%
des investissements qui sont financés
par prêts bancaires
alors naturellement ça a un effet
dévastateur alors monsieur lui dis ça à
la question est relativement simple
compte tenu du contexte compte tenu que
la réaction de la réactivité dont on a
besoin
l'efficacité ce dispositif mériterait
d'être vraiment revu à la prochaine loi
de finances parce que je sais très bien
c'était 85% l'assiette en 2013 et 74
pour 75 % en 2014
on ne sait même pas combien s'arrêtant
en 2015 avec le problème de non
visibilité fiscale d'instabilité
juridique ça perturbe fortement la
confiance
voilà une mesure assez simple qui ne
manque pas d usine à gaz type du cic eux
qui permettrait je pense de redonner
assez rapidement confiance aux
investisseurs
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur cette disposition qui
permettait finalement à des grands
groupes
je vous la fais simple parce que l'état
c'est simple à comprendre permettait à
des grands groupes
si la raison de son abrogation de son
tempérament tout quand on amodiations
les grands gros pouvait acheter par
l'endettement des entreprises procéder à
des fusions acquisitions par la dette et
c'est finalement la fiscalité qui
subventionnait des parfois des
entreprises périlleuses de fusions
acquisitions donc cela nous paraissait
une erreur c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles cette facilité de déduction
déductibilité des charges d'intérêts a
été limitée n'a pas été supprimée été
limitée puisqu'elle était intégralement
déductibles
elles le sont une façon plafonné et je
voudrais dire que les pme et tpe ne sont
pas concernés par cette mesure puisque
le montant des charges financières au
delà duquel le plafond déductibilité ne
s'applique mais ne s'applique pas est
inférieur un seuil de 3 millions ce qui
permet à des entreprises de disposer de
la même facilité dès lors qu'elles ont
une taille modeste
est ce qu'il faut faire bouger encore ce
seul puisqu'il a été âprement discutée
en loi de finances devant les deux
assemblées
je n'en suis pas certain je crois que
c'est un dispositif qui était
économiquement absurde
on ne peut pas subventionner par des
déductions fiscales
l'acquisition par des grands groupes
d'entreprises d'ailleurs situé dans le
monde alors qu'elle accède facilement au
crédit et peuvent financer ses
acquisitions d'elle-même
en revanche pour les petites entreprises
qui ont des problèmes de trésorerie des
problèmes d'endettement je crois que la
mesure est toujours active
donc on peut considérer que il y a là un
poids moyen qui a été définie par
législateur il faut bien sûr
l'expérimenté le gouvernement est
attentif à ces questions mais je crois
que là nous avons peut-être finalement
une mesure qui peut avoir une longue
carrière
merci mon cher collègue suisse il existe
quand même déjà des dispositifs
anti-abus mais la cible c'est la vôtre
c'est votre cible la cible c'est les pme
pmi qui veulent accéder à
l'international
or je sais très bien que c'est 3
millions et le plancher
or quelle est la cible nous avons à
peine 1000 entreprises qui exportent les
allemands non 5000 donc celle qu'il faut
vraiment aider c'est votre cible
c'est celle au dessus de 2 3 millions
c'est celle de 3 400 employés 5 600
employés qui valent accéder aux marchés
internationaux à l'exportation et c'est
celle ci qui malheureusement sont plus
les plus touchés monsieur le ministre je
pense que sur cette question il peut y
avoir un accord
on est toujours en train direct a pas
d'accord majorité opposition voilà une
des questions sur lesquelles on pourrait
trouver un accord et il ya déjà des
dispositifs anti-abus assurent les
intérêts liés sur les cessions autorise
etc
monsieur le ministre très bien merci la
parole à joël guerriau pour le groupe
u10 merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues dans la
bataille pour l'emploi et la croissance
un des leviers essentiels qu'il faut
favoriser l'accès des pme pmi au
financement de leurs investissements
mais aussi à la consolidation de
l'entreprise leur trésorerie nous en
sommes tous convaincus
c'est un problème récurrent est censé
être lié par les chefs d'entreprises qui
font vivre le tissu économique de nos
territoires
ils sont tous tous les jours confronté
aux réticences des banques à prendre des
risques à leurs côtés vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre la mise en
place par le gouvernement de la banque
publique d'investissement bpi france
avait vocation à ouvrir à canal public
de financement bancaire aux côtés du
canal traditionnel de la banque privée
je rappelle que cette structure a
d'abord repris des dispositifs qui
étaient des gens place tels que ce qui
existait au sein de zéro ou du fonds
stratégique d'investissement avant même
que soit envisagé de nouvelles
propositions d'accompagnement la loi
organique relative à la création de bpi
france spécifie clairement la mission de
soutien de l'institution publique aux
pme
quel bilan après plus d'un an
d'existence de la bpi deux difficultés
majeures nous sont sans cesse relayée
dans nos départements
la première difficulté bpi france se
positionne trop souvent concurrents des
banques plutôt qu un allié des
entreprises en ciblant prioritairement
les entreprises qui n'ont pas de
difficultés d'accès au crédit attendrait
à évincer les banques privées la
deuxième difficulté qui nous remontent
ces les garanties mises en place par bpi
france en complément des prêts bancaires
qui sont assorties de tels délais
d'entrée en application que les
établissements bancaires nous ont
recours que pour des entreprises la
situation historiquement scène en
conséquence ces possibility ses
possibilités bénéficie insuffisamment à
des entreprises récentes ou innovantes
ou connaissant des difficultés
passagères
ma question est donc de savoir comment
cet établissement public peut être mieux
orientée en faveur du soutien aux pme
pmi de nos régions
par exemple en réduisant les délais que
je viens de citer
d'un trek comment parvenir à un meilleur
respect par bpi france de l'objectif
fixé par l'article 1er de la loi
organique de décembre 2012
merci monsieur le ministre le sénateur
je ne crois pas que la bpi soit un
concurrent menaçant pour des banques qui
serait évincé je le crois pas d'abord
parce que la bpi
c'est l'équivalent du d'une caisse
régionale du crédit agricole en taille
donc je ne crois pas que la bpi qui a
cette taille-là est en train de menacer
le chiffre d'affaires de bnp paribas
société générale et c'est donc la vérité
c'est que les banques attend que bp ils
viennent mais bpi est une banque plus
patiente et moins gourmand que les
banques privées on l'a conçu comme ça
son taux de retour sur investissement
c'est pas les 12% qui permet au
président exécutif de bnp paribas
d'augmenter encore de 10% cette année
son taux de retour sur investissement
c'est pas de 12 à 14% comme l'exigent le
secteur bancaire privé pour distribuer
les dividendes en veux tu en voilà
ces 4 % en dessous la banque postale
donc c'est une banque original atypique
et c'est une banque qui doit rester
rentable car il est hors de question de
recommencer la mésaventure du crédit
lyonnais
je le dis à tous ceux qui auraient des
inquiétudes donc elle n'est vince
personnes elle est en concurrence avec
ceux qui refusent le risque est là pour
refuge il rit je peux vous dire il n'y a
pas beaucoup de monde il ya beaucoup de
monde au portillon
en revanche pour l'assumer ah là là bpi
est quand même là d'ailleurs qu'est ce
que c'est que j'ai comme retour de
vous-même parlementaire et lui dire
d'écouter la bpi ne prend pas assez de
risques
et là c'est la décision du banquier que
d'équilibré de mutualiser série dans son
portefeuille mais jeu proposera ainsi
aux banques qui se plaignent auprès de
vous monsieur le sénateur de venir
suppléer aux éventuelles défaillances
d'abbé pays qui on verra si les banques
acceptent de prendre ce risque
je crois qu'il ne faut pas inverser
l'ordre des priorités ni même d
détails et des poids et des mesures
alors voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
néanmoins je crois que le bilan de la
bpi mériterait que vous auditionné son
directeur général parce que lui-même une
politique ultra volontarisme c'est le
bras armé du redressement productif de
la reconstruction notre économie qui
était très abîmée dans ces années de
crise et les progressions en en cours ou
la bpi intervient c'est ce qu'on appelle
les prés de développement seuls sont des
progressions qui sont programmés à
hauteur de 31% en plus pour l'année en
cours
nous étions à + 6 % l'année dernière ce
sera plus 30 % donc nous avons là quand
même une responsabilité qui est assumé
donc moi je vous invite à discuter
directement avec les dirigeants la bpi
c'est normal d'ailleurs que les élus
discutent interpelle et contrôle d'une
certaine manière car il s'agit d'argent
public
ils disent ils de politique publique et
il s'agit d'un bien public que cette
banque
elle appartient à tous les français metz
le j'espère que vous l'aurez entendu à
mon cher collègue monsieur le ministre
je vous écoute avec beaucoup d'attention
et je m'interroge parce que je considère
que dans mac estivants dans la terre
d'autorisation qui était la mienne
c'était de souligner qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de concurrence entre les deux est
le mot que vous avez utilisé à plusieurs
reprises sur des entreprises solvables
il doit y avoir une complémentarité je
trouve que les propos que vous tenez
sont de nature à diviser film en eau de
monde sur lequel vous portez souvent à
comment on doit accusateur en
particulier sur sur nos banques privées
considérant que finalement elles sont
plus des adversaires et non pas des
alliés dans le cadre d'une bataille
qu'est la bataille de la croissance
je rappelle quand même que les autres
que les banques eux sont soumis à des à
des lois et des réglementations très
très durs qui sont nées notamment de la
situation de 2008 dans le cadre de la
crise financière qui a entraîné
finalement ses ventes finalement à être
peut-être plus frileuses dans le risque
parce que elle porte des obligations et
des ratios qui sont tels qu'elle doit
bien forcément être en mesure de
démontrer leur capacité à les tenir
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
monsieur me disent que nous devons être
dans un logique qui est plus une logique
de complémentarité c'est à dire que vous
devez porter et fédérer des mesures qui
permettent d'avoir d'un côté évidemment
les entreprises solvables sur lequel
tout le monde est d'accord mais comme
tout le reste
et en particulier je pense qu'une des
questions qui était soulevée à plusieurs
reprises les crédits de trésorerie qui
sont le véritable oxygène dans les
périodes justement on manque de contrats
ou dans les périodes où effectivement
les entreprises vient son tour des
difficultés pour tenir très bien merci
la parole à claude bérit-debat pour le
groupe socialiste
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre chers collègues
cela a été a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises devant moi si les statistiques
indiquent que que les conditions d'accès
au crédit bancaire semble satisfaisante
la perception des chefs d'entreprise est
tout autre cette question rebondit
aujourd'hui autour d'une idée qui fait
son chemin et qui consisterait à dire
qu'il faudrait que les pme puissent
émettre des actions et des obligations
sur les marchés grâce à ce que l'on
appelle superbe oxymore à mon sens la
titrisation scène
je ne crois pas pour ma part que ce soit
une bonne chose il me semble d'ailleurs
que cette idée est contredite par le
fait que les banques accroissent eux bel
et bien leur offre de crédit auprès des
pme et des tpe
ainsi à titre d'exemple les caisses
d'epargne viennent d'annoncer leur
volonté de prêter plus de 13 milliards
d'euros aux entreprises orale inverse
des grandes entreprises et des eti nos
pme et tpe
ont-elles traditionnellement une
relation qui demeure privilégié avec
leur banque
aussi pour nous aider à sortir de la
crise nous devons reconsidérer ce lien
pour cela nous devons inventer de
nouvelles formes mx2 financement qui
tiennent compte des nouvelles exigences
en matière de fonds propres
légitimement imposé aux banques dans ce
but
monsieur le ministre ne pensez-vous pas
que nous aurions tout intérêt à
consolider le métier de nos banques pour
que nos pme et tpe puissent continuer à
bénéficier de bonnes conditions deux
financements à des taux modérés et
compétitif comme c'est le cas en ce
moment
surtout il nous faut garantir que la
diversification des sources de
financement auxquelles nos pme et nos
tpe devons recourir ne se fera pas à des
conditions plus onéreuse et plus
contraignante pour elle
comment
le ministre le gouvernement compte-t-il
les y aider et à y parvenir
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole il est bien certain que
l'expression titrisation a subi le sceau
de l'infamie dans la crise des subprimes
ce le sénateur puisque les titres et ses
mécanismes de financement était un moyen
de dissimuler les actifs pourris comme
on dit zhang bands qui était mal choisie
qui était mal notés mal contrôlée donc
l'émetteur et le contrôleur était
d'accord pour lé surévaluée à partir de
là nous savons comment l'économie a été
entièrement contaminé par la titrisation
ce que nous observons dans toute
l'europe c'est que le secteur bancaire
étant défaillant les entreprises
cherchent directement s'adresser au
marché les pme le peuvent moins que
d'autres parce que ce sont des
entreprises qui sont généralement non
cotées quand elles le sont la cotation
est sur un marché étroit
la question du risque et mal évaluées ou
mal évaluables et la recherche du titre
est la mutualisation du riz sur des
titres qui sont évidemment un assemblage
de titres de pme permettant à celle-ci
de mutualiser le risque de leur
financement les précautions éthique qui
sont que nous partageons avec vous
monsieur le sénateur nous amène à penser
que si ce marché doit se développer
il doit se développer sous le contrôle
de la banque de france qui disposera
d'ailleurs d'une notation qui elle est
au dessus de tout soupçon n'est pas
soupçonnable de conflit d'intérêts comme
je crois un certain commissaire au
marché intérieur l'avait déclaré à
l'encontre des agences de notation
privées
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles dans un cadre extrêmement
déontologique il nous paraît utile de
développer des capacités de financement
direct sur le marché et c'est le moyens
par lesquels les assurances vie la
banque centrale européenne entendent ou
en temps l'une et l'autre imaginez
injecter de l'argent directement dans
l'économie sans passer par le secteur
bancaire je rappelle encore un mot
monsieur le président vous permettez
qu il y a trois ans ou quatre ans la
banque centrale européenne à refinancer
tout le système bancaire à hauteur de
1000 milliards d'euros dans toute la
zone euro et le résultat c'est que les
banques n'ont pas utilisé cet argent et
ont remis la moitié de la somme dans les
livres de la banque centrale européenne
donc c'est donc qu'il y avait bien un
système qui ne fonctionne pas le canot
le canal historique du financement de
l'économie réelle est embourbé nous
devons imaginer d'autres voies de
financement et nous les travaillons
ensemble
merci monsieur bérit-debat vous aurez
compris monsieur le ministre que j'aime
et et quelques doutes que j'étais pas
favorable à cela mais vous me rassurer
puisque vous nous dites que ça peut se
faire dans une
dans ce cadre mme ans dans un
encadrement strict avec la banque de
france je voudrais je voudrais toutefois
vous vous remercier pour les actions qui
sont menées en matière de financement de
pme et de tpe
on n'a pas qu'est on a parlé tout à
l'air tout à l'heure d'un certain nombre
d'organismes de soutien et je voudrais
donc vous dire que le la politique que
vous menez aujourd'hui me semble aller
dans le bon sens c'est ce qui me remonte
de nos territoires par rapport je dirais
ce qui est attendu d'une politique du
gouvernement dont merci de ce que vous
faites et j'espère que pme et tpe
pourront continuer à recourir au crédit
sans avoir besoin de forcer la main aux
banques qui a encore une fois ne jouent
pas toujours le jeu vis-à-vis des
petites et moyennes entreprises et
notamment des relations de confiance
qu'il faut établir amer j'ai entrepris
merci la parole catherine procas ya pour
le groupe e
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre dans les tpe et les pme 70% de
l'activité sont financés par les
collectivités et les petites communes
la faillite de dexia a réduit de 17
milliards d'euros par an les capacités
de financement des collectivités
leur montant s'élève dorénavant à trois
milliards et demi
où trouver les milliards qui font défaut
dans son projet le premier ministre
concernent le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi qui est
surtout on sait bien favorable aux
grandes entreprises et qui est une usine
à gaz
si on le supprimait on disposerait de 20
milliards d'économies pour financer les
petites entreprises
rappelons que les tpe n'ont pas la
possibilité d'assurer un fonds de
roulement en jouant sur les délais
clients et fournisseurs comme dans les
grandes entreprises la réforme bâle iii
a contribué à épuiser le crédit bancaire
et bpi france jouent le jeu mais ne
répond pas aux attentes
mes collègues l'ont souligné avant moi
les faillis des micro entreprises sans
salarié et des tpe ont bondi au premier
trimestre 2014 selon le cabinet d'études
altares depuis le début de l'année près
de 7000 micro entreprises ont déposé le
bilan
800 de plus en un an et 8455 petites
entreprises ont connu des procédures
collectives
sans compter que le développement du
commerce sur internet qui menace bel et
bien le petit commerce qui est au coeur
de nos cités face à ce constat
quels moyens comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre monsieur le ministre pour sauver
le petit commerce et de manière plus
générale assurer le financement de nos
très petites entreprises
je n'utiliserais pas mon droit de
réponse pour que mon collègue puisse
poser lui sa question
merci en tout cas sa réplique monsieur
le ministre
même le sénateur je ne crois pas que le
crédit impôt soit une usine à gaz les
entendu déjà deux fois
c'est une baisse d'impôt qui est
appliquée uniformément sans condition et
sans contrôle ça nous a été suffisamment
reproché
donc je ne vois pas d'où vient l'idée
que c'est une usine à gaz s'était
peut-être compliqué de l'anticiper par
les mesures de préfinancement mais ça au
moins a le bénéfice de la simplicité
la seule condition c'est qu'il puisse en
être discuté dans l'entreprise avec les
partenaires sociaux ce n'est quand même
pas trop demander qu'est ce qu'on fera
de cet oxygène supplémentaires dans
certaines entreprises se sera consacrée
à l'emploi les embauches parce qu' il
manque du personnel pour faire le
travail que dont l'entreprise a la
charge
ce sera une machine dont on a trop tardé
à faire l'acquisition ce sera peut-être
la conversion de cdd en cdi ou tout
simplement la remontée des marges
d'autofinancement pour redonner de la
force et être capable d'emprunter donc
le crédit d'impôt combi 18 emplois nous
avons reçu avec le premier ministre la
semaine dernière l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et patronales
commence à s'installer comme étant une
mesure qui est maintenant là et avec
laquelle chacun peut travailler
d'ailleurs personne n'a demandé la
remise en cause dans le cadre des
extensions du pack de responsabilité
vous me permettrez de dire un mot sur
les toutes petites entreprises dont vous
signaler les difficultés vous signaler
d'ailleurs le contenu de l'enquète
altares qui vient de paraître sur le
premier trimestre 2014
nous avons un phénomène contrastée d'un
côté les pme de plus de 50 salariés qui
connaissent une chute spectaculaire du
nombre de familles de faillite
- 28 % et en même temps une montée dans
leur micro entreprise des faillites ce
que vous est défaillante que vous avez à
juste titre signalé
c'est d'ailleurs tout le sujet de notre
politique nous avons un problème d'offre
que nous sommes en train de faire de
conforter de performant de compétitivité
de l'appareil productif et les premiers
effets se font sentir moins de plans
sociaux plus de sauvetage de grandes
entreprises j'en ai citer quelques-unes
tout à l'heure et des pme
qui se conforte et des secteurs de la
production industrielle qui repartent
avec des niveaux de production
intéressante très positif et puis tout
ce qui est l'économie de proximité
servicielle où là il y à un affaissement
c'est la question du pouvoir d'achat
ainsi sous les mails etc si je mens posé
et d'ailleurs c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles dans le pack responsabilité
il y a cinq milliards qui est consacrée
au pouvoir d'achat des ménages pour
soutenir aussi la demande
il y a un problème d'offre de
compétitivité mais aussi de demain merci
la parole à andré reichardt pour le
groupe ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre en qualité de ministre du
redressement productif vous avez inclus
dans les 34 plan de reconquête
industrielle de la nouvelle france
industrielle un plan relatif à l'usiné
du futur destiné à faire entrer la
france dans la troisième révolution
industrielle
vous avez dit ainsi je cite que pour
retrouver son rang dans la bataille
mondiale pour à gagner en compétitivité
la france est mise au double défi de
moderniser son outil productif d'une
part de concevoir et de développer les
processus de production de demain
d'autres pas vous avez souhaité associer
à ce plan les régions chef de file du
développement économique et avait avancé
dans les premiers échanges avec
l'association des régions de france une
aide de l'état de 1,2 milliard d'euros
sous forme de prêts bonifiés uniquement
financés par le programme
d'investissement des investissements
d'avenir numéro 2 or le 7 avril dernier
les régions ont appris par la presse qui
citait le pilote du plan usine du futur
que ce plan pourrait bénéficier d'un
milliard d'euros d'investissements co
financé cette fois par le programme
investissements d'avenir l'état et les
régions
mais question sont donc les suivants
quel est le montant que l'état propose
effectivement d'allouer au plan usine du
futur en lien ou non avec le programme
investissements d'avenir et hors fonds
régionaux sous quelle forme
quand ils en faire un volet des futurs
contrats de plan état région et 6,8
selon quels principes et enfin
l'allemagne a engagé monsieur le
ministre vous le savez bien dès 2012 un
plan de 40 milliards pour faire entrer
son industrie dans la quatrième
révolution industrielle appelé
zinn 4.0 dans ces conditions quelle
assurance at on que notre plan usine du
futur nous permettra d'honorer vraiment
la compétition avec l'industrie
d'outre-rhin et ne se limitera pas un
simple rattrapage notre retard en
matière de modernisation les pme
particulièrement nombreuses dans ma
région attendent naturellement de savoir
quel sur quels financements et notamment
s'il s'agit de prêts bonifiés
comment le seront ils merci merci la
parole à monsieur le ministre monsieur
le sénateur les 34 plan industriel sont
à l'ensemble visant à transformer notre
offre industrielle
ils sont pilotés par les industriels eux
mêmes dans le cadre du conseil national
industrie que le premier ministre
président
institutionnellement ses 34 plan
contiennent parmi un de ses 34 un plan
usine du futur qui a pour objet de
moderniser en passant en enjambant une
génération technologique de moderniser
le plus possible de tei de pme pour leur
permettre de conquérir la compétitivité
technologique celle qu'on appelle hors
coûts nous avons un programme
d'innovation qui concerne tous les
secteurs de l'industrie à travers les 34
plan automobile aéronautique industrie
du bois numérique bref vous je vous
renvoie à l'ensemble de ces secteurs
d'ailleurs l'ensemble de l'argent public
qui est investi au titre de la totalité
de 34 plan est de 3 milliards 7
je puis vous dire que dans certains de
ses plans industriels par exemple la
chimie la chimie verte notamment le
secteur industriel de la chimie envisage
d'investir sur plusieurs années
la somme totale de 4 milliards donc
quand vous mettez boutabout l'argent
public et l'investissement privé
nous allons arriver d'ailleurs nous
sommes en train de le chiffrer à des
niveaux d'investissement qui sont assez
similaires à ceux que vous évoquez
s'agissant de l'allemagne sur l' usine
du futur nous avons fait une chose tout
à fait innovante
nous avons dit aux régions aux conseils
régionaux vous connaissez votre terrain
vous connaissez vos pme c'est vous qui
les choisissent et je ne veux pas de
contrat de plan de paepe là et c'est
parce que nous pour nous c'est une
politique très simple qui ne consiste
pas à programmer des sommes qu'on
distribue il suffit d'aller repérer des
entreprises qui en ont besoin
avec des dirigeants d'entreprise qui le
veulent qu'ils sont prêts à le faire et
nous sommes présents au niveau de la
robotique et une déduction fiscale dans
la loi de finances qui permet la
déduction l'amortissement accéléré sur
les investissements de robotique en 24
mois ça a été saluée par tout le monde
ça c'est le premier point d'appui le
deuxième nous mettons 250 millions de
d'argent au titre du grand emprunt
nous souhaitons que l'argent européen
mobilisés par les régions puisqu'elles
ont maintenant désormais la main là
dessus puissent venir abonder les
efforts du pays acp mais ce sont les
régions qui ont la main les régions
ne s'intéresse pas à l'industrie seront
absentes les régions qui s'y intéressent
et certaines sont passionnés elles
seront très en avance je ne sais pas si
c'est une bonne politique que d'avoir
choisi les régions mais je pense que
c'est quand même la première
responsabilité d'un territoire que de
s'intéresser à cpm
je lance un appel à travers vous à vos
conseillers régionaux pour que ceux-ci
se mobilisent sur le plan usine du futur
merci mon cher collègue andré reichardt
les messieurs ministre au regard des
caractéristiques industrielle de
l'alsace et de sa proximité avec
l'allemagne le sénateur alsacien que je
suis mais qui est aussi premier vice
président de la région alsace vous
remercie et vous indique que s'agissant
précisément de la spécificité de gens de
son tissu industriel constitué notamment
dans une pme dans l'industrie et de la
mécanique
joe resterait vigilant sur ce dossier et
aimerait naturellement être rassurés à
cet égard l'allemagne comme je les dis
avec son plan usine 4.0 est en train de
mettre en place une industrie dans
laquelle communiquent entre elles les
machines on a qu'elle communique ses
machines avec les objets les services
entre eux c'est chez eux c'est déjà la
quatrième révolution industrielle est en
marche et ceci doit nous interpeller
avec vigilance mais aussi et beaucoup de
volontarisme c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut absolument que soit
mise en place
à côté de ces de ces pme une batterie de
d'instruments financiers leur permettant
naturellement de prendre ce virage à
leur tour elles sont déjà en retard il
faut leur permettre également de sauter
quand vous le disiez 7
cette phase pour aller elle aussi à la
quatrième révolution
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h pour l'examen en
deuxième lecture du projet de loi pour
l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et les
hommes
la séance est suspendue
voilà vous ai donc pu suivre la séance
de questions cribles des questions
cribles consacrée aujourd'hui au
financement bancaire des petites et
moyennes entreprises
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur public sénat